oh yeah
[Music]
bacala explorers has searched for it for
centuries
yeah the Golden City it's a
technological marvel technically the
king
if anyone found out what we truly are
what we possess
it could destroy dois irmãos man it is
my duty to protect it embarrass my son
this is your time one module co-op
cuckoo
the king of Wakanda is here
how much more you hiding it is lighter
[Music]
completely it absorbs energy for
redistribution
black pant I waited my entire life for
this
the world's gonna start over I'm gonna
be on top what do you want I want the
tomorrow
the revolution will guide me
happy new year everyone so Michael B
Jordan was doing more interviews about
his kill monger character and we learned
more about the golden Jaguar costumes so
I wanted to talk about the costumes
specifically like kill mongers golden
Jaguar costume versus Black Panthers
energy costume some of the differences
in the reason why it's so similar to
Black Panthers costume it have their
technology inside the Marvel Cinematic
Universe differs from Iron Man suit
technology like we've already seen other
versions of Iron Man tech when we got
the spider-man homecoming suit we have
the new infinity war spider-man suit so
if wakandan technology is supposed to be
light-years beyond everything else how
is that different from Iron Man's
technology so I'll explain all that but
if you are finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos there's gonna be a whole bunch of
black panther dropping in the next
couple weeks if you didn't know the
movies premiering Valentine's Day
weekend in February and there's a new
round of that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway
Michael B Jordan says some interesting
things about his character during his
last big interview so he specifically
called out Heath Ledger's Joker
performance as inspiration for some of
his scenes as well as magneto in terms
of his relationship with Black Panther
the magneto Charles Xavier relationship
which gives you an idea for why he might
have a costume that looks like it was
designed by Sheree because we actually
saw it Anna version of the trailers and
it looks like he goes for a good portion
of the movie without wearing it so at
some point in the movie he has to get
his hands on that but it makes sense
because it has a lot of the same
functionality as the Black Panther
energy costume so like you hear Sheree
narrating during that trailer completely
bulletproof absorbs energy for later
redistribution and then during the
trailer you see him redistribute some of
that energy which is kind of like this
comic book panel here one of the big
differences in the golden Jaguar costume
even though there are a lot of hidden
functions like during spider-man
homecoming we had an idea for what his
costume did but they were still a couple
secret functions like instant kill mode
I could catch them all right-handed this
is awesome okay I'm gonna get a little
closer so I can see what's happening
would you like me to engage enhanced
combat mode or enhance combat mode yeah
activating instant kill no no no no no I
don't want to kill anybody really cool
function gonna come in really handy
during infinity war but not something
that you would have known about going
into the movie so with a name like kill
monger you can imagine he has much more
lethal vibranium based weaponry built
into his suit so in the way that they
can both form around them out of these
smaller pieces they call that suit
manifestation
he's also wielding these two blades
those aren't part of the costume but
there are also blades projectiles that
manifest out of these metal looking
vibranium pieces now the whole suit is
vibranium but some of it is solid metal
vibranium like the belt in the necklace
here and some of it is vibranium weave
you always have to go back to that old
ultron joke about how dumb most people
are because vibranium has so many
different properties it's beautiful
the vibranium atoms aren't just
compatible with the tissue cells they're
binding them and she never even the most
versatile substance on the planet
and they used it to make a frisbee so it
goes way beyond the idea of just making
simple armor the armor itself has a lot
of built-in functionality because of
vibranium properties things that Iron
Man does not have access to so where as
Peter Parker
Iron Man always get continual upgrades
but they have a heads-up display they
have more traditional mechanized parts
the black panther suits are sort of the
wakandan version of that but they're
much more elegant in their form and
function but obviously there's a lot of
Secrets that they won't reveal till an
infinity war because everybody gets
upgrades they even let us know that
Winter Soldier gets a vibranium arm so
I'll link that video at the end of this
because the Rousso did that big Q&A when
he talks about him being like his
magneto - Black Panthers Professor
Xavier
it sounds like they didn't always use to
be enemies but in the comics and in the
movie his family gets exiled by Black
Panthers family so that becomes this big
division so he comes back but there's
this weird parallel between them in that
he's just as powerful as Black Panther
but Black Panthers physical power comes
from eating the heart-shaped herb so if
Co monger is supposed to be as powerful
as he is then maybe he was able to eat a
bit too but usually it's really bad if
you're not a member of Black Panthers
family and you try to eat it it could
wind up killing you so there's still a
lot of things that they haven't answered
about how they've changed kill monger
from his comic book cells but they have
changed it quite a bit but let me know
in the comments who do you think has the
shot at building the coolest costume do
you think that Black Panther could come
up with something cooler than Iron Man
technically it's Sheree that designs all
his costumes or do you think as has been
the case in the past Iron Man will
always have the coolest technology and I
know I haven't done an Iron Man video in
a little while but this is actually his
infinity war suit it's a version of this
that can basically become anything that
he needs it to it's much more modular so
like instead of having to climb into a
Hulk Buster it could turn into a Hulk
Buster but because they already have the
old one in the trailer I'm not expecting
there to be two different hulkbusters
although there is a wakandan hulk buster
that is really badass hopefully we'll
see it someday but everybody happy new
year leave all your requests for bonus
videos this week and because so many
people are traveling for the holidays
I'll be posting updates in that top pin
comments so just check there for the
videos that I'm working on next and
there is a new round of that Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and just use
the YouTube tools on this watch page
here to share the video somewhere and
congratulations to the winner from my
last Marvel video King see a rill oh
please private message me so I can get
your contact details click here for that
video where they talk about all the
upgrades characters are getting and
click here for more black panther thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]